Hello internet,
Here we are: 500,000 abbonees - well, actually by the time this video is online.
Even a little more than that - But who would have thought that after I promised to do a Q&A
The pope would abdicate.
Anyway...
When I uploaded my first explanation video now just over 2 years ago, I never had one
Expected the following: More than half a million abbonees and 16 videos with more than one million views. Who
Did you know that quickly recorded eductive videos would be so popular?
Thank you, Internet.
Well, as promised - Just a little behind schedule - it's time for a few of you
Answer questions.
## "What is your study background?" Rodrigo, Campo Grande, Brazil
I went to school in New York where I earned two high school degrees, one in physics and one
in sociology. Then I moved to London and got a PGCE in science education, and
I became a qualified physics teacher in England.
## "How much time does it take to make one video?" Tracey, Ohio
I have kept time to find a precise answer and every minute of video costs
Writing and animating me between 10 and 20 hours. So a typical 5 minute video
is 50 to 100 hours of work.
Although that is a lot, it is not including the research phase that is rather difficult to measure.
- For some of the videos I made, I had been collecting notes for more than a year before I started.
## "What was your favorite video to make?" Brittany P, UK
The 2012 video was by far the best. - mainly because I don't get a whole lot complicated
had to do research and I could complain about things that I don't like.
## "What kind of change would you make to the education system?" Lumba jacket Gangsta, Austin, TX
Instead of sorting children by age, I would sort them by wealth.
The idea that just because a child is fourteen years old he is ready for trigonometry is strange. No
only other part of human society organizes itself in this way and for good reason:
delayed the best and the smartest.
## "What do you think should be in the box but not in it?" Jamaal, Arizona
Computer programming. I was a bit shocked and horrified when I started teaching in it
UK and discovered that there were no real programming lessons.
Of course, there are only a certain number of lessons per day, and everyone wants their favorite subject
in the roster, so an equally important question is what has to go to make room
for programming and without a doubt I would
removing foreign languages ​​- programming brings us closer
the perfect translator.
## "What do you do when you get pennies?" johnjac, owasso
I die a little bit inside, thinking about how political systems can contribute small costs over large
numbers of people to help the few.
## "What is your favorite element?" Rasmus, Denmark
I don't have a favorite but I have something with Tungsten, especially because of my
wedding ring made of it.
## "What is the story behind your logo?" Joshua B.
It is a personal flag for my love of science and technology.
When I started this channel I thought I was mainly going to make videos about that
two things, but for several reasons that hasn't happened yet.
And, it's not like there is a shortage of good science channels on YouTube.
By the way, if you like the logo you can get it on T-shirts and now also coffee cups
- which is quite logical since coffee is the fuel without
these videos could not be made.
## "What do you do in your spare time?" Sam L, Higginsville, MO
I like to ride a horse through the mountains.
Nah, it's usually just Reddit.
Speaking of Reddit ...
## "Would you rather fight 100 horses the size of a duck or 1 duck the size of a horse?" techtakular,
Alex, from
A duck the size of a horse. The square cube law says that the legs of a duck the size of a horse are likely
not be very stable. Easy
## "Will there be more" Politics in the animal kingdom "videos?" Oli
Yes, I'm sorry. I know that the playlist is not finished yet and if videos are important
Then those are.
I promise at least one more about the single transferable voice, but I don't make any promises
when it comes.
## "Do you think third parties will ever get land in the United States?" Kerl, Florida
No.
The problem is not politics or voter indifference, it is the system that makes politics
and tuner indifference.
The US electoral system is pretty much the worst in the civilized world - vaka is voting
for a third party not only a waste, it is also a vote 'against' your own interests.
Third parties cannot really thrive under such circumstances.
## "What is a technology that you would like to see before you die?" zigonick, MO, USA
Immortality.
## "Where do you get your ideas from?"
It is my experience that creative projects are self-supporting. The more you write
the more things you want to write and the more you program, the more programming ideas
You get.
In my case, each video provides more videos. For example, the daylight saving time video originally
there were pieces in it for information about longitude, time zones and the season that cut out of sentence
but eventually become their own videos.
I also listen to a monstrous amount of audio books and pdocasts. If you are interested you can go here
See a few of my favorites. They help me stay in touch with the wide world
and to expose me to ideas and information that I would probably not bump into on my own.
## "If you could live anywhere in history, what would it be?" Bonnie, Scotland
I would not do that.
Allow me to list the entire human existence with this graph.
## "What is the best way to become successful on YouTube?" Joe Kowalski, 44074
Make videos that people want to see.
I am not trying to be smart but when asked this question I see many YouTubers talking about it
the importance of regular uploads and the management of your social media and collaborations, and
my experience says that it is completely the other way around.
If your videos are not interesting, no one cares that you upload them regularly.
And Twitter followers do not provide views. views provide Twitter followers and people
who want to work with you.
I know it's not helpful advice, but it's the most honest advice I can give you.
## "What is the most interesting fact that you have ever been told?" Stu1278, England
It is difficult to find one from a whole life, but last year visited Veritassium
me in London and walked with me through the process by which trees water from their roots to theirs
bring leaves.
That sounds boring but it was one of the most mind-blowing conversations I had
in years.
## "How often do you work with professionals on your research?" theLarom,
DC
For me, being confused and frustrated with a topic is an important part of figuring out how
it should be explained to others, so I would say that I do 95% of my research alone.
If a subject really does not suit me - such as the debt video and the pope video - I try
very hard to find an expert who can check the end result but lacks time
and the difficulty of finding a good expert often gets in the way.
## "What is your favorite internal organhat is your favorite internal organ?" trint99, DFW, TX
The brain - because they are me.
## "Is there a science that you wish was wrong?" Jrod N, Massacusetts
Yes, the current interpretations of the ultimate fate of the Universe make me sad.
## "Can you answer 10 questions in 30 seconds?" YouReadMeName
## 1: "What is your favorite scientific study ever published" Marie, Reno, NV
Unskilled Are Unaware: Further Explorations of (Absent)
Self-Insight Among the Incompetent
Link in the description.
## 2: "Hogwarts house?" Zeinoun Awad, Lebanon
Ravenclaw. (I would hope)
## 3: "Celsius or Fahrenheit?" Kubez
Fahrenheit.
## 4: Kirk or Picard
Picard.
## 5: "Are you wearing glasses?" Spartacus McFancy Pants
Uh, yes.
## 6: "Favorite empire?" Caleb Glickman, USA
The second. Those monks were amazing.
## 7: "How can a country be completely self-sufficient - if in no import or export?" Amberjack1973
Simple, go back to medieval technology.
## 8: "Favorite sport?" soccernhlfan, Canada
No.
## 9: "Should science play a greater role in politics?" Dip, London, UK
What do you mean the way of finding out the truth? Yes, I think it should.
## 10: "Can you answer 10 questions in 30 seconds?" YouReadMeName
Apparently.
Okay, thanks everyone who asked questions - it was fun, Internet.